Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist eigentlich los beim FC Liverpool? Diese Frage kann man mit deutschen Journalisten klären. Man kann aber auch mal die Experten vom FC Liverpool fragen. Und die habe ich mir jetzt eingeladen. Die Anfield Raps sind hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das hier ist mal wieder eine Folge im Rahmen des Junior Cups. Das heißt, wie schon letztes Jahr erfolgt hier der Hinweis, ich bin hier beruflich, das heißt, nicht in Rasenfunkmission. Ihr könnt diese Folge natürlich trotzdem hören. Ihr könnt sie besonders kritisch hören, ob ich vielleicht diesem Turnier besonders positiv gegenüberstehe, weil es eben Teil meines Jobs hier ist. Aber ich glaube, diese Folge ist es sehr wert, gehört zu werden. Denn ich habe zwei hervorragende Gäste, für die ich ins Englische switchen muss, auch wenn uns das jetzt allen ein bisschen wehtun wird. Ich möchte mich hiermit schon mal bei euch entschuldigen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die Anfield Wrap ist hier, in Sindelfingen, bei den JuniorCups. Kind of an inside joke, these are the best ones that nobody gets, but the one that made them. Would you please, Josh, start with, explain to my listeners, what is the Anfield Wrap?
The Anfield Wrap is a Liverpool podcast based in Liverpool city centre, which mainly shares experience with other fans from all over the world really. We've got fans from as far out as Australia and fans in the city of Liverpool. Our aim is to share the match-going experience with them. So we go to Liverpool games home and away and have done since 2011, making podcasts, previews, reviews and analysing every single game. We have a couple of jokes in between and have a bit of a laugh with it, so we like to think.
Yes, so we did Beginner's Podcast in 2011. We've done those in Norway, all around Scandinavia, in America, in Australia, in Ireland, in the UK, all over the world. And yeah, we sell t-shirts as well, which is diversification. So yeah, we do a lot of things, but mainly the Anfield Wrap is about sharing the experience.
And the reason I wanted to talk to you, in a way we are repeating our talk we had yesterday. We talked so, so good about Liverpool, about Jürgen Klopp, what has changed at your club and what is to be expected from the Champions League match against FC Bayern Munich. So that I said, okay, we have to repeat this exact conversation again and I will record it and as always this will work out fine. So Josh, explain us, what has happened since Jürgen Klopp arrived at Liverpool?
Well, I think it sort of starts before Jürgen Klopp arrived at Liverpool really. There was a massive distance created between almost the club and the fans and the fans are obviously, especially in Germany, the fans are such a big part of the club. When Jürgen Klopp came in, it was like a fresh new perspective on everything where for him he was buying players that he knew he could trust and then that meant that we could trust them as well. We could trust them to do the business on the pitch, but we also knew they were good people, people that we could rely on and people that knew cared about us and I think that's probably something that didn't exist at Liverpool in the past was that there wasn't that trust between the players and fans. Klopp really brought that bond close together and he always worked since the start. I remember the words in his first press conference, which are sort of ever used from Liverpool fans and probably even further afield now is that he wanted to turn doubters into believers at Liverpool. And I think at the time there were a lot of doubters and I think now you're finally starting to see the results of Klopp's progress that we are becoming believers.
Okay, but when you say it started before Klopp with the owners, who are the owners, Craig? And what did they do to create this gap between the fans and the ownership and the club?
The Anfield Wrap was born out of that, was born out of the fact that between 2008 and 2011, Liverpool were owned by two Americans, who had somehow managed to acquire a football club as big as Liverpool with absolutely no money. And so they were taking money from the club.
They were kind of modern Houdini's.
Exactly.
How did they manage to do that?
I have no idea. I think back in those days there wasn't the same kind of screening process that there is now, with new owners coming in. And so they'd managed to get themselves in a position where they owned the club, they made promises to the fans that they would sign big players, they would build a new stadium immediately. And none of these things happened. They sack Rafa Benitez, they bring in Roy Hodgson, who will go down as one of the worst managers ever, well, if not the worst manager to ever manage Liverpool Football Club. And yeah, they had no money to spend. The transfer strategy was terrible. The people at the top of the club didn't care about the club, they didn't know about the club, they were businessmen. And they certainly weren't Liverpool supporters. And so Liverpool almost went into liquidation because of these owners. And they were kind of saved in some way by the current owners, FSG, who come in, bought the club, when really they probably were businessmen as well, who saw an opportunity to buy a club as big as Liverpool for a cheap price and make them big. And as businessmen, that's been a brilliant business decision by them. But they've also been able to take Liverpool to a new level without really spending mass amounts of their own money. We definitely haven't been bankrolled in the way that Man City or Chelsea have. We've almost organically built ourselves to this position now, where the clubs run brilliantly as a business. We look across at Germany and we see this. We see the impact that fans can have in this country. We're getting closer to that. We've got a team on the pitch who are one of the best, if not the best Liverpool side I've seen in my lifetime. I'm 27 years old. I'm headed by a manager who has transformed the whole club from top to bottom and who we fully trust.
Okay, I want to start to go back furthermore. My question is, when did it start that Liverpool was sold to an owner?
So he was a local businessman. He'd owned the club for many years. I suppose he was almost sold this dream of Hicks and Gillette, who were these two American cowboys, as Craig neglected to call them, two Americans who rode into town full of promises and with very little actually in their pockets. And Liverpool, as we explained to you yesterday, Max, is a city which is a very activist city. That includes Rafa Benitez, includes all the supporters. So when you say, how do we get rid of bad owners? When Rafa Benitez got sacked, it just ramped up even more, because Rafa almost became the spokesperson for Liverpool supporters in that he used his press conferences to publicly come out against the owners and say that he wasn't being given the money that had been promised and that all these promises that they'd come into town with had been completely broken and that Liverpool fans were not going to see these rewards. And Rafa did such a good job during his time at Liverpool of making the most out of a squad which he almost had to just fund himself. We sold loads of huge players for not so much money when you look back on it and the money was then, even the little amounts of money that we sold these players for, were not reinvested into the playing squad. The activist mindset of Liverpool supporters meant the protests went on and on until the point where Craig mentioned liquidation and administration became a possibility for Liverpool.
Okay, and who are those guys?
So they own the Boston Red Sox and there's a great movie about the Boston Red Sox and their business model called Moneyball whereby they got rid of players on big wages who weren't performing anymore and they brought in younger players who had the possibility of being sold for a higher price. They bought young English youngsters for high prices but small wages and it didn't quite work out for them. I think that's probably because they came from America, they didn't know much about football in general and how that works and how if you pay a certain amount for a football player it doesn't mean that you're going to get that. So they were paying big money for some players and it didn't work out. That problem continued throughout Kenny de Glish, throughout Brendan Rodgers reign. It was really only when Jürgen Klopp took over at the club that he began to work closely with a guy called Michael Edwards. Together they've managed to transform Liverpool's transfer strategy. It feels like every single signing that they've made has been a success. Apart from Loris Karius, of course. But when you look at the players that we've signed, Mohamed Salah, Sadio Mane and beyond that, Virgil van Dijk, some of those players are for massive amounts of money. Virgil van Dijk, Alisson, one of the most expensive goalkeepers in the world, the most expensive defender in the world. But they've also signed some hidden gems. Andy Robertson at left-back, who is probably the Premier League's best left-back at the moment. He was signed from Hull, who had just been relegated. So they've been astute in everything they've done and there seems to be a plan now within Liverpool and Liverpool's transfer process. But at the beginning of FSG's reign, that wasn't always the case. We signed Charlie Adam. After we'd sold Fernando Torres.
So what is now the role of Jürgen Klopp and what of Michael Edwards is it right?
So when Klopp came in, Edwards was moved across to Sporting Director, which is obviously a very similar model to what you'll see in Germany quite frequently, but he's mainly now the person who will build up the packages of information on players and he'll take them to Klopp and then him and Klopp will have an open discussion. So it won't just be like Michael Edwards sits down and says, Jürgen, I think we should sign this player and then Jürgen goes, yes or no. I imagine it will be, what strengths can he bring to us? How does he do this well? Does he do that well? And then they sort of make the decision from there and like Craig said, we've benefited from it so much so far because there's players who've come in who have just completely hit the ground running and we were talking to someone from Austria before, me and Craig, about Sadio Mane, because obviously he played for Salzburg over there and I think in Austria the opinion was that he probably wouldn't be able to go on and make it a big club and it's probably quite a shock to them that he went on to play for Liverpool and at the time when we signed him, there weren't many Liverpool fans who were very excited about him either, but that first season still remains probably his best season at the club, his most effective season at the club, alongside Philipp Coutinho and Roberto Firmino, Es ist jetzt eine viel mehr erhöhende Art, wie du denkst. Es ist eine massive Influenz, was Jürgen Klopp in die Hälfte gebracht hat.
In der Vorstellung des Finals war in England die News, dass Liverpool Mario Götze signieren würde. Liverpool-Fans waren so begeistert, weil das eine große Anfehlung wäre. Also signierte Liverpool Sadio Mane. Der Fanspieler ist ein anderer Spieler aus Südhamen. Das gleiche mit Andrew Robertson aus Hull. Das gleiche mit Genie Winaldem aus Newcastle. Auch Mo Salah. Aber eine der lustigen Geschichten von Mo Salah ist, dass es kein Jürgen Klopp-Signing war. Es war ein Michael-Edwards-Signing. Michael Edwards und sein Team haben Jürgen Klopp gesagt, dass Mo Salah ihn schauen sollte. Mo Salah hat vorher für Chelsea gespielt, aber es hat nicht wirklich funktioniert. Er hat alles, was er kann, in Bezug auf persönliche Akkulaten.
Die Worte Trust sind das wichtigste, das Craig gesagt hat. Auch bei den Toren der Bordesrunde und der Managier-Office war die Trust nicht da. Das Konjoin-Thinking war nicht da, aber jetzt ist die Trust sehr da.
Okay, wir sehen viele gute Transfers. Wir sehen eine Kooperation, die wir vorher nicht gesehen haben. Es sieht so aus, als ob alles zu Gold war. Unter den Händen von Jürgen Klopp. Aber in der ersten Stelle musste er mit den Sachen, die er an Steck hatte, arbeiten. Wann war das erste Mal, dass du dachtest, dass wir hier etwas Besonderes machen?
Ich denke, dass Jürgen Klopp's ersten drei oder vier Monate am Klub sehr hoch und runter war. Jürgen Klopp war ein grosser Name für Liverpool-Fans, die als Manager kamen, besonders nach dem Spiel mit Brendan Rodgers.
Wann kam hierher?
Wir hatten viele Spieler, die nicht mit dem, wie Jürgen Klopp spielen wollte, so wir mussten mit dem, was wir hatten. Ich denke, das erste Mal, als wir alle realisierten, was wir hatten, wollte ich das Dortmund-Spiel sagen, als wir sie in der letzten Minute gewonnen haben. Aber es war wahrscheinlich nicht das, es war wahrscheinlich, als wir Manchester United gespielt haben, in der Europa League, in der Runde vorher, wo wir sie zu Hause 2-0 gewonnen haben. Dann gingen wir zu Old Trafford für den zweiten Platz, und Manchester United ging 1-0 hoch. Und in der Vergangenheit hätte Liverpool gespielt, Manchester United hätte gewonnen, um sie zu gewinnen. Philipp Coutinho schießt 2 Minuten vor dem Halbzeitpunkt, das ziemlich gut umfasst. Das war eine leidensame Zeit für die Liverpool-Fans, weil wir in Old Trafford für die Hälfte des Spiels gewonnen haben, weil wir die Flere durchgehen. Ich glaube, das war der Moment, in dem wir realisieren, dass wir, ob wir viele Trophäe mit Jürgen Klopp gewinnen oder nicht, viel Spaß haben werden. Das haben die Liverpool-Fans in einiger Zeit nicht gehabt. Wir haben jetzt drei Finals in Jürgen Klopp gewonnen. Ich weiß, dass die Leute in Deutschland wissen, dass er die Finals gewonnen hat. Das ist schon passiert, aber wir haben als Fußballfans die besten Nächte in unserer Leben genossen. Wir haben uns auf der Liverpool-Seite angeschaut und die Wins von später erhebt.
Ich kann dir garantieren, wenn er ein Finale gewinnt, wird es ein 5-2 gegen Bayern.
Das ist, wenn Bayern da sein können.
Wir wissen, was Jürgen Klopp in Mainz und Borussia Dortmund an sich hat. Wie würdest du seinen Stil des Spiels in Liverpool anzeigen und wie es sich seitdem entwickelt hat?
Liverpool war etwas unterstehender. Sie haben eine Art, ich weiß nicht, was du in Deutschland nennst, aber ein Schmuck im VELVIC-Gelübchen. Du hast die schöne Interplay zwischen Salamani und Firmino. Wir hatten es in den Rafa Benitez-Days wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Ich denke, es sind definitiv verschiedene Phasen. Wie Josh gesagt hat, in den Anfangen waren wir nicht ein guter Team, um das zu machen, was er wollte. Was er von der Seite bekommen hat, war die Stamine, das Arbeitsgrad, das man erwartet hätte, aber es war nicht unbedingt die Qualität. In seiner zweiten Saison hat er viel gelernt, im Hinblick auf Englisch-Football. Das bekommt man in England nicht. In der zweiten Saison war Liverpool in der Qualifizierung für die Champions League. Es war wie über die Linie, weil Liverpool sich auf den Boden verbrannte. In der letzten Saison hat er gelernt, dass er sich an die Runde dreht. Wir sahen Rotationen im Derby gegen Everton. Wir sahen ihn einfach... Firmino wäre auf der Bühne. Jeder würde sich fragen, warum ist Firmino auf der Bühne? Aber es war Jürgen Klopp, rotiert. Das Champions League Finale passiert. Das war ein massiver Thema. Es war ein massiver Thema, aber für mich ist es einfach nicht... Er hat einige Fehler gemacht. Dann kam er wieder zurück, hat vier bis fünf Monate gespielt, ziemlich gut. Dann kam der Champions League. Das kann nicht in die Konkursion gesetzt werden. Das passiert. Wir mussten uns alle über das einhalten. Aber am Ende des Spiels waren wir enttäuscht. Aber es war das Beginnende. Wir hatten jetzt einen Liverpool-Fans, der mit den besten spielen konnte. Mit einigen Signen, mit Nebby Cater und Alisson und so weiter, konnten wir endlich gewinnen.
Du hast alles geschwächt, nur für diesen Titel. Wie hat es angefangen?
Es hat angefangen in einer sehr untergewöhnlichen Art. Und dann, in der 97. Wer dir jetzt gesagt hätte, dass Liverpool in der Position wäre, hätte dir gesagt, dass du ein totaler Schlamm bist. Die Everton-Fans waren so sehr begeistert, als Van Dijk den Schuss schiebte. Aber dann geht es wieder zurück, Jordan Pickford versucht es zu fangen, er schiebt es aus der Bar, dann ist Divock Origi da. Es ist eine perfekte Reisekommando für ihn, er war ein Spieler, der komplett ausgespielt wurde. Ich erinnere mich an die Straßen des Anfields nach dem Spiel. Es war wie ein Party, wie ein Karneval in London oder ein Art Street-Festival, wo jeder dachte, dass das Liverpool-Team etwas tun würde. Wir konnten die Resultate ausgrinden. Es war ein Teil von uns, das wir hatten. Die Leute waren bereit, für die Seite zu warten, die auf Feuer setzt und das Metall ist schwer.
Aber definitiv war der Weihnachtszeitpunkt der Veränderung. Es fühlt sich verrückt an, am Anfang der Saison zu schauen. Ich denke, am Weihnachtszeitpunkt, als wir das begannen zu passieren, haben wir Man United, Arsenal gewonnen. Es war nicht gegen Man City.
Weißt du, was das Error ist? Ist es nicht etwa 15 Millimeter? Ich weiß, dass im Jahr 2015 oder 2016, der FIFA oder der UEFA, ich glaube, es war der FIFA, den Error von 30 Millimetern, das ist verrückt, wenn du mich fragst, von 15 Millimetern, und das war, als die German Football League sich entschieden hat, wenn wir einen Error-Margine haben, dann können wir die Golan-Technologie in Deutschland auch auch diskutieren.
Wir kamen so nahe, und es hat dann den Torhüter getroffen und Salahs Beine und so weiter passiert.
Everton und andere Spiele in den ersten wenigen Wochen der Saison. Es sah immer aus, als hätte City nur noch die Dinge, die sie vorher in der Saison ohne Kevin De Bruyne gemacht haben, und nur noch warten, als Chelsea und Liverpool anfangen, Punkte zu verlieren.
Man kann die Zufallung sagen, dass man sich von Losen ausgeschöpft hat, und dass wir nicht 10 Punkte klar waren. Aber Manchester City hat ihre Stil fast komplett gealtert, um zu sehen, was sie sich besser gegen Liverpool spielen können. Das ist ein Zeichen für die Lufthansa, weil sie Manchester City in 2018 mit der Premier League-Anfield-Game verabschieden haben. Die Schockerlänge haben sie mit der 4-3 und der Champions League-Anfield mit der Anfield-Game verabschieden. Auch die ETH-Game, in der die einzigen Diskussionen mit der City nicht qualifizieren, nicht nur, dass sie nicht das Spiel gewinnen, aber auch Liverpool zu gewinnen, das Spiel 2-1 zu gewinnen, das war unerhört. Die City hatten es in der ETH-Game gerade. Du brauchst es in den Situationen zu sehen. Es ist ein Zeichen, wie weit Liverpool jetzt Klopp und Guardiola sind. Dann wird es die Balance ansteigen. Es ist aber nur eine konstante Wettbewerb zwischen diesen beiden, die wahrscheinlich die besten Managern in der Welt haben und die besten Taktikblüten in der Welt haben. Wir sehen es wieder. Es gibt der Premier League eine ganz andere Dimension.
Ja, Bring the Noise. Du siehst diese Guardiola gegen Klopp, Guardiola mit den Reichen von Bayern München und Manchester City. Manchester City ist der rechte Oligarch, und Liverpool der... Resortsvoll. Wir sind reich, aber in der Premier League sind wir wahrscheinlich die Abstecher. der Champions League Final mit uns, er hat auch mit Dortmund gespielt. Und das ist Klopp's dritte Vollzeit.
Okay, ich bin total zufrieden mit dem. Es wäre eine wunderbare Geschichte, die nur Fußball kann schreiben, wie wir es hier in der Rasenfunk sagen.
Ich hätte nicht den Podcast aufkommen können, wenn ich die Anfragen hätte.
Für mich ist es ein Liverpool-Team, der vielleicht in Jahren vorbei ist, aber du wirst sie nicht vertrauen, um den vier-Punkten-Lead zu halten. Aber es ist ein Liverpool-Team, der dir jetzt mehr vertrauen würde, um einen vier-Punkten-Lead zu halten. Die einzige Lose der Saison ist jetzt in Manchester City. Das Vertrauen ist von den Fans da. Ich denke, das ist bei uns passiert. Wenn du endlich ein Spiel nach so langer Ungeheuerung verlierst, denkst du, dass das Liverpool-Team jetzt, die sich dafür befinden und auch mit der Hoffnung, auf anderen Fällen zu kämpfen, auch dabei zu sein.
Ich kann das auf einem Podcast sagen, weil ich weiß, dass niemand in England mich so sagen wird. Aber es gibt etwas in mir, das wir immer glauben, wenn es um den Liga-Titel geht und Liverpool den Liga-Titel gewinnen, dass Liverpool dann nicht den Liga-Titel gewinnen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist und was es sich so fühlt. Denn als Liverpool-Fan haben wir das nie gewonnen. Wir haben alles in meinem Leben gewonnen. Was ist das zweitens erfolgreichste Teil in England? Aber ich denke, wir werden es dieses Jahr gewinnen. Ich denke, dass die Grundlage dafür, dass Liverpool in meinem Leben zwei Titel-Races gewesen ist. und 14. Runde, als Gerard Slips am Ende war. Ein Teil war 2008 und 2009, als Liverpool Manchester United den Titel gespielt hat. Ich denke, dass sie 2013 als 3. Es war ein Winnerstreak, das am Ende der Saison kam, das sie in den Titel-Race gezwungen hat. In England gibt es kein Team und kein Klub in England, das besser Momentum hat als Liverpool. Du hast die Szene gesehen, wo der Bus durchkommt, es gibt Pyro und so weiter. Dann bringen wir Roma in Anfield. Es gibt das Momentum, die Leute, die Atmosphäre, alle sind gespannt, und Liverpool gewinnt. Dann gehen wir zu Roma. Das ist das Momentum, das baut. Sie sind sehr gut, das zu hernassen. Und Jürgen Klopp auch. Jürgen Klopp ist am Vordergrund.
Wenn du in München kommst, was erwartest du aus der Champions League? Was ist dementsprechend anders, wenn du die ganzen Spiele in der Grube-Stage verloren hast, jetzt nach Bayern getragen?
Ich kann mir Assumptionen machen, wo sie in der Bundesliga sind. Sie sind die einzige Bundesliga-Team, die ich diese Saison gesehen. Habe. Ich denke, wenn Liverpool an die Allianz gewinnt, wird das Problem, dass sie nicht in der Saison in Europa gewinnen, weg. Ich erinnere mich an die Gespräche mit dir gestern, wo du von der Anfieldszeit zu Beginn gesprochen hast. Max hat mir erst mal erinnert, dass Liverpool in der Saison die Quarta und die Semi-Finals am Anfield gewonnen hat. Aber ich denke, dass die Liverpool-Team jetzt fast anders ist als die, die wir in der letzten Saison gesehen haben. Die Dimension, die Alisson hat, und die Spieler wie Fabinho und Naby Keita, die sich auch wieder an den Füßen finden. Diese Team kann nun auf europäischer Wege anders in der Gruppstage gehen, weil es so viele Monate und Wochen vorhanden werden. Und sie können Resultate auf dem Konzert bekommen, weil das solide Wettbewerb, das wir vorher eröffnet haben, gerade übernimmt wurde.
Er ist skeptisch. Nein, nein, ich bin nicht. Wir sind aufgeregt und haben unsere Fußballzeit für das erste Mal in Jahren. Für viele Liverpool-Fans haben wir das noch nicht geschafft. Das ist spannend, und ich denke, es ist der Treffer der Runde. Ich habe nicht genug von Bayern Munich gesehen, um zu sagen, ob wir sie definitiv gewinnen, ob wir sie nicht, aber ich denke, dass Liverpool das Spiel, das jeder Team nicht wollte. Ich denke, das ist der Grund, warum wir sich selbstverständlich in die Spiele fühlen. Und es sind einige Wochen weg.
Wir wissen nicht, was passiert wird. Aber beide Teams müssen das Beste für sich haben, um in diesen Spielen zu spielen. Es sollte also ein paar Situationen geben, dass Liverpool das höchste Bar für Bayern München auf dem Niveau der Eier zu setzen, und dann können sie sich an die Eier auf einander treffen. Aber was bedeutet die Champions League nach dem Spiel? Du hattest diesen wundervollen, wundervollen Sieg über Milan. 2005, glaube ich. Es ist ein Teil der Fußballgeschichte, wie es im 1999-Final auch war, aber unter viel mehr schmerzigen Situationen. Du bist so jung, dass du dich wirklich nicht erinnern kannst. Du warst in der letzten Jahr so nah. Aber wer will, wenn du in die Elimination-Runde gehst, und dann gewinnst du alle Dinge. Aber du hast auch diese Titel-Race.
Es ist interessant, weil ich denke, als wir in die letzte Saison zum Finale gingen, haben wir in der Champions-League die beiden Dinge fast begleitet. Du wirst es in der Saison sehen. Ich hoffe, dass Jürgen Klopp auf dem Wort, was er dieses Jahr gesagt hat, folgt. Er hat ein Team gebaut, das er sich auf einigen Gründen zueinander zurechtführt. Ich möchte, dass wir in die Liga gehen. Nicht unbedingt, aber wir müssen in beiden Sachen ein Seriöse-Challenge machen. Es ist jetzt der Zeit, die Realität zu erzielen, weil Liverpool nicht wieder die Chance hat, die Liga zu zahlen. Wie in der vergangenen Saison, Gott sei Dank, habe ich mein Herz gebrochen, dass das nicht passieren würde. Und das Hauptwichtigste ist, dass wir es im ganzen Wettbewerb genießen. Du weißt ja, dass du genau wie ein Fußballer auf diesem Stande klingeln kannst. Die Champions League ist so... Ich meine, wir könnten die Eventus nächste Runde schreien, in welchem Fall, wenn ich an diesem Podcast sitze, dann würde ich total andere Dinge sagen. Ich denke, die Eventus werden wahrscheinlich zu stark für uns über zwei Lagen sein. Ich denke, dass wir die Liga gewinnen können. Aber ich denke, wir haben jetzt einen Team, der auf beiden Fällen eine Challenge machen kann, sobald wir gehen können.
Wir haben sie 2005 gewonnen, und ich war zu jung, um in die Liga zu gehen. Ich war glücklich, in die Champions League zu gehen. Im Finale des Jahres haben wir es nicht gewonnen, aber ich denke, das, was wir alle für so lange wollen, ist möglich. Ich denke, wir können noch gegen Bayern gehen. Ich denke, wir können noch weiter gehen, an die die wir in die nächste Runde spielen. Das fühlt sich wirklich wütend an. Wir haben schon seit Jahren Bayern München, Man Utd, Chelsea und alle anderen Teams in der Champions League gesehen, wo wir nicht in die Champions League kommen konnten. Ich möchte, dass wir spielen und ich würde es lieben, nichts mehr zu gewinnen als die Champions League zu gewinnen. Aber das, was die Liverpool-Fans so lange gewartet haben, ist das Liga-Titel. Aber für uns sind es 28 Jahre und das sind zwei Generationen Fußball-Fans. Das ist mein ganzes Leben. Wir haben das Team nie geliefert. Ich denke, dass der Moment, als Liverpool die Premier League eröffnet, der Monke auf der Kante ist und wir mit unseren Leben weiterkommen können. Wir können uns nicht mehr absetzen und wir können aufhören, weil das Problems von Liverpools sehr viel aus dem Grund stammt, dass sie es nicht so lange gewonnen haben, während unsere Rivalstöne es gewonnen haben. Ich denke, dass wir das einmal gewinnen können, und die Stärken werden beherrscht und wir können endlich unsere Leben weiterleben.
Die Entfernung in den Garten von Eden. Jürgen Klopp ist jetzt ein Künstler, aber dann wird er ein Legende sein.
Aber ohne diese Trophäe, die er noch nicht hat, wird es nicht unbedingt passieren, bis er es bekommt. Wenn es der Liga-Titel ist, ist es dann der größte Wandel.
Jürgen Klopp weiß, dass alles, was er tun muss, als Liverpool-Manager, das Liga gewinnt. Wenn er das Liga gewinnt, wird er ein Gott für die Liverpool-Fans. Er kann das Liga gewinnen und nichts für die 3 Jahre danach gewinnen.
Du hast gesagt, dass das das Anfang ist. Es ist wirklich faszinierend, mit jemandem zu sprechen, der so tief in die Fan-Kultur und auch in die German-Fan-Kultur ist. Vielen Dank für eure Zeit. Ich habe ein paar schlechte Gramma-Mistake gemacht, aber es ist zu spät. Und das ist ich, die Englisch spricht. Make it well.